you know I've said throughout this
entire process that what is so important
is that we ultimately unite behind who
that Democratic nominee is and I think
it's a two-way street I've been
concerned by some folks that say of
Bernie's the nominee they won't support
him I'm and the other way around
Oh Wayne congresswoman you're always
welcome to come on this show we will be
respectful well tough questions but
you're always welcome now she went on to
say in the same interview that all the
illegal immigrants should fill out the
2020 census also tonight
congresswoman Omar is pushing racially
divisive rhetoric to new extremes not
surprising but sad take a look it is to
recognize that our history is built on
the oppression of black bodies from
slavery to Jim Crow to redlining to mass
incarceration to fullest oppression
racism is part of the foundation
meanwhile the Trump campaign they are
fighting back against the hate Trump
media mob suing fake news CNN for
allegedly pushing malicious Russia fake
news in hysteria a complaint filed today
specifically cites an article written in
June of 2019 here with reaction
Trump 2020 campaign national press
secretary Kelly mcenany and former White
House press secretary looks much better
out of green our friend Sean Spicer is
back Caylee we start with you you know
it's there's a very high high bar when
it comes to any public figure you know
yet you have to show there was no malice
okay it doesn't matter the bar is so
high and I think these laws should be
changed personally because I think
people get away with slander and smears
all the time tell us specifically why
the campaign thinks this will be
successful look we think it will be
successful because there's no denying
that CNN that the Washington Post that
the New York Times have all displayed
malicious intent they knowingly
published false information I totally
agree with you Sean the libel laws
essentially now allow you to slander in
that's libel anyone and that's why
Justice Antonin Scalia said they need to
change but we have to work within the
structure we have right now and you
cannot go out there and lie knowingly do
so peddle this Russia collusion
narrative and think you can get away
with it this lawsuit is an effort to
hold the fake news accountable bottom
line and Sean Spicer I mean one of these
I liked about the Nicholas Sandman suit
and there's nobody better than Linwood
Charles harder the Gawker Kate those are
the two go-to guys in this country and I
will tell you that he is it as a kid
they didn't even ask to do one bit of
research and then even what was known
was proven false they continued the
slander of this kid I would love to know
the amount if I had to venture a guess I
did I guess only I guess I bet CNN paint
over a hundred million dollars to that
kid they had to wouldn't take a white
house in my opinion
I hope so they ruined his life and and I
mean I'm sure he's gonna live with this
forever there'll be a Google search
every time it comes up so I hope he got
a ton of it but look I just want to say
this CNN in particular leads the
sanctimonious charge about Donald Trump
misleading and false things and how many
times the washington post you know
counts every statement and yet when they
will falsify a report and in Kelly's
right I mean this is just made up they
make a false allegation they walk away
from it they get caught lying misleading
all of the above when they do it it's
okay they but they are the first ones to
go after Donald Trump day in and day out
and call every Republican and every
conservative and yet they dismiss what
they do on their air every single day
and what their correspondents do to
demean Donald Trump as the president and
every other conservative and it's so
unbelievably wrong and no one except for
you and the rest of your teammates Sean
call this out it is so ignored and so
washed over by the rest of the media
it's unbelievable all right good to see
you